Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This is a neural network-based method that
is able to show us the sound of pixels.
What this means is that it separates and localizes
audio signals in videos.
The two keywords are separation and localization,
so let's take a look at these one by one.
Localization means that we can pick a pixel
in the image and it show us the sound that
comes from that location, and the separation
part means that ideally, we will only hear
that particular sound source.
Let's have a look at an example.
Here is an input video.
And now, let's try to separate the sound of
the chello and see if it knows where it comes
from.
Same with the guitar.
Now for a trickier question...even though
there are sound reverberations off the walls,
but the walls don't directly emit sound themselves,
so I am hoping to hear nothing now, let's
see... flat signal, great!
So, how does this work?
It is a neural-network based solution that
has watched 60 hours of musical performances
to be able to pull this off, and it learns
that a change in sound can often be tracked
back to a change in the video footage as a
musician is playing an instrument.
As a result, get this, no supervision is required.
This means that we don't need to label this
data, or in other words, we don't need to
specify how each pixel sounds, it learns to
infer all this information from the video
and sound signals by itself.
This is huge, and otherwise, just imagine
how many work-hours that would require to
annotate all this data.
And, another cool application is that if we
can separate these signals, then we can also
independently adjust the sound of these instruments.
Have a look.
Now, clearly, it is not perfect as some frequencies
may bleed over from one instrument to the
other, and there also are other methods to
separate audio signals, but this particular
one does not require any expertise, so I see
a great value proposition there.
If you wish to create a separate version of
a video clip and use it for karaoke, or just
subtract the guitar and play it yourself,
I would look no further.
Also, you know the drill, this will be way
better a couple papers down the line.
So, what do you think?
What possible applications do you envision
for this?
Where could it be improved?
Let me know below in the comments.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!